Desde el grupo de la izquierda
apoyamos esta propuesta de pacto de migración y asilo.
En primer lugar,
porque criminaliza a las personas migrantes
y suspende y retrocede en derechos.
En segundo lugar, porque lo que antes era 1 escándalo,
las terrealización y militarización de fronteras,
ahora se convierte en ley.
Y en tercer lugar, porque cancela el derecho al asilo.
Eso nosotras proponemos, 1 alternativa.
En primer lugar,
vías legales y segura de entradas a la Unión Europea.
En segundo lugar,
1 unidad de salvamento y rescate
en el mar Mediterráneo.
Y en tercer lugar, utilizar
todos los recursos de la militarización
y externalización
para políticas de acogida digna
y generar 1 estado social fuerte
con servicios públicos de calidad
y empleo en los lugares de llegada a la Unión Europea.
Desde la izquierda
vamos a seguir peleando por ampliar derechos de todos
y de todas